Monica Geller and Phoebe Buffay trade
the Big Apple for Beverly Hills Courtney
Cox and Lisa Kudrow made all of our
friends dreams come true on Tuesday
nights this is kind of a classy place
okay say no more when they were
photographed leaving dinner at the Palm
giving each other a big kiss on the
cheek goodbye and giving us major feels
[Music]
Petey caught up with Lisa and Courtney
in 2016 and they revealed where they
think Phoebe and Monica would be today
we'd be married of like Connecticut guy
right or they were like a Upper East
Side New York family it's probably
raising all of her little kids and she's
cooking and she's with Chandler and
they're happy and he probably got a job
you know it's smoking steroids and
putting in the drawer and some kind of
Bank or something I don't know what did
he do what was Jan there I wouldn't know
what he did find out what he Davis John
as for those Phoebe spin-off rumors Lisa
told et in March no way no no no Phoebe
works with the other people for sure
[Music]
Oh